an old lady was a phone nak Atlantic
they probably did
do you watch digit hurdles when you were
growing up Nick I doubled the devil to
you he just dabbled who dabbles a ninja
turtles I mean I wasn't like a
skateboarding pizza kid but I enjoyed
them over my life like I'd like to ask
people like who's their favorite turtle
like if you could be one of the turtles
which one would you be then always
thought there's like a clear favorite
like Leonardo has two swords like that's
way cooler than the guy with the stick
but I've realized in asking people which
Ninja Turtle they could be that I think
there's a perfectly even distribution of
turtles and personalities that
correspond with them today I want to do
a little science experiment and ask
people which Ninja Turtle is their
favorite my hypothesis is that we'll
find an even turtle spread for everybody
in the office my favorites Leonardo
we'll start there lay down who's got one
hey Sam
what up who's your favorite Ninja Turtle
probably Donatella because he's Perkins
smart he's not a joker like the rest of
them sorry to interrupt your really
important work what's your favorite
engine turtle leave Donnie
all the way with you miserable the
reason why he doesn't know he was born
the same way the matrix came out who's
your favorite Ninja Turtle its route
okay
I'm Leonardo you once or bloom ass baby
so I've got three for Leonardo - for
Dante land two for Raphael Michelangelo
I guess has no fans here so far pretty
even across the board how's the day
going great we're just about to get
really started so obviously we got here
early I've also set up people are
getting a wardrobe getting miked up
cameras been built camera team and neek
up and going through the shot list and
now we are just about miked up and ready
to get our first shots off so the day is
really just beginning
how many shots we got to do today about
10 maybe 11 or 12 close-ups you can do
that and do that I'm directing I focus
on one thing that's directing and that's
it he's quiet might not look at too much
but he knows what he's doing inside
there
laser focus that's the director for you
we are trying to get a medium wide
establishing shot where we capture both
Alicia and the robber in the background
all with a sort of left to right
movement to make an interesting frame or
as Nico would say a sweet shot the key
to all this is to make sure nothing
beats fast enough and you know if
courage we can edit to be a really fast
commercial
miles younger my favorite was always
Leonardo cuz he had the two Kitab he had
like the two swords and he's a leader
but Raphael is my favorite now that I'm
older interesting ways this whole thing
where like everyone's favorite in
general isn't who they are what I mean
you think that people spend in tutorials
like the opposite of your personalities
yeah kind of I heard this theory that
everyone's favorite infertile is not
actually sure who they would actually be
it's who they think they would be or
wish they would be reject themselves
very aspirational so I always liked
Leonardo the best but then as a group I
realized I'm like way more Raphael so
this is a straight son shot right it's
very harsh I'm squinting so obviously
shadows but then you get right under the
flag there's just an even lighting nice
and soft basically use the sunlight to
even everything out and watch your shot
perfectly direct Sun so direct Sun
so it's really nice to have Google
resources
hurry on schedule I don't want to answer
that why not because I don't like the
answer you want to want today
if you're an integer which one need to
be I you know I would always think of
myself as more of a Donatello but I've
got a spiciness to me I'm more of a
Raphael
people tell me I'm a Raphael you know
growing up I loved Mikey but I think as
an adult I'm probably more of a Leo
we've got to do something you know it
says that all the time Oh Donatello
hundred percent 100 percent watching the
old show they could never have any
adventures without Donnie he'd always
make a gadget and then that would be the
entire episode would be like oh I made a
portal to something and then that's
their episode there he's holding true
except for Michelangelo which Ninja
Turtle the G B can you say most
important things being a DP is having
alone no it's a hat it's a hat honest
God advice if you want to be a DP just
get that super sweet hat the rest takes
care of itself
Sunseeker I highly recommend it to any
do you pee coming up in the world that's
called Sunseeker we start to get some
direct Sun 11 to 11:30 our conditions
will change drastically at that point
basically it allows you to track the
movement of the Sun so you can tell when
it's going to screw you you can also
track the moon but that's really not
used we're planning on setting some
shots planning on making them some sweet
shots we're gonna get a mob chasing
after our villain I consider them a hero
but I'm kind of a dickish gamer so yeah
we've got a couple plans for the first
shot up we're gonna go
and try to get our character Bob he is
running away from camera turning back
and giving us a devilish smile so we're
gonna try it on the long lens and use
our Dana dolly to try to simulate
movement with him if we can't pull that
off I'm gonna jump on that there one
wheel and I'm gonna use that they're a
7n I'm gonna try to get the shot off the
hip often Oh how does it work you get
your fancy chair here I do is it
actually comfortable okay camp chair
probably better you don't like sit down
very far you guys stick their legs out
you're standing cuz if you get up a lot
there's like a list of like the top 50
tips from Roger Deakins our students
feel Berger or whatever the director of
the moment is and the tip that they put
on every list is find time to sit down
if you have it because it while standing
on set so if I move my chair up here
sitting sit down once in a while
extremely low what are the odds of Jan
getting a super sweet shot [ __ ] 100%
you're gonna follow the actor while he's
running that's blown with an eight 7s
yep on one wheel yep all right one more
time all right
I think so action
zero-one speak thanks so yeah cool
yeah so what's cool but yeah enough
coffee actually think of a payment what
if they to bring up a six by take me
fairly bad 5-10 minutes to grab Jared
and you'll will be done thank you yeah
crippling just had more bounce
what boils down to is you guys are
basically the cloned of that angry mob
chasing chasing Frankenstein here except
in your hands are coffee cups and phones
and those kind of things this character
here he's been running around destroying
you guys what this shot we're going to
be doing is stuck with this 3/4 angle
here if Tim's off to the side Roberts
gonna be in front of you guys about n
feet or so maybe 50 look at your exact
positioning with the camera in a second
here you guys be running behind top with
your fists in the air and what the other
thing we're going to do here is we're
going to be throwing stuff it's going to
be on a certain rhythm run throw action
three victims over a little bit so that
they're more in frame bunch of I lines
movement now all sorts of guts that's
how conceited we are we compare
ourselves to the Renaissance great to
the Masters but they didn't they didn't
understand gravity or none of that so
yeah they're about to and they didn't
make movies either
I heard 85 85
am i holding this for a second of course
not mom thank you just hold that up for
camera do it man yeah I'm gonna pretend
this isn't fine fine Sigma 85 cinema 185
one of the best numbers to Masonic
number for those of you in the
conspiracy world no it's not it's not a
Masonic 33 s a Masonic number what's the
important tip we're swapping lenses
whatever you're handing it off between
you and another person remember to give
some sort of audio or visual
confirmation that you have the lens in
hand
such as mine or got it or nod and a wink
so far so good I think you tuckered
himself out it's probably taking a nap
right now yeah you know probably a
couple times a day it's like like a baby
you know like baby gets hungry baby
cries baby gets tired baby cries yeah
location one of their to about commish I
see it complete do now we're headed to
the beach get our last scene and this
commercials are at baby
[Music]
I think we've ever filmed on Venice
Beach Ben Bohr we filmed in Malibu on
the beach well the first and foremost
challenge is that it's hard to get gear
out here even if you have the right moon
wheels and things like that for removing
large dollies it's just hard to get
stuff out here because we got across the
quarter mile beach the sand everywhere a
moment of surprise moment like oh no /
[ __ ]
currently we're on the Sigma 35mm cinema
pointed 35 it's a good ones length
that's not quite as wide as the 24 so
you can actually get a little bit of
depth of field in your frame and it's
not quite as tight as a 50 it's a nice
mid-range lens it's a good way to
establish a scene
what happens when your just give us
don't know about it's not her fault yeah
she was just acting but we didn't clear
him far back enough during the foot she
okay yeah an old lady was the phone
uterine feel nice it probably really
hurt did it really hit her eight
[Music]
yeah it's a practical effect shot and it
will light the ground element okay
where where is that gap sorry I have it
sideways neither turn it we're good to
get an insert shot of throwing the phone
into the water and Christina here has
volunteered to be the one to grab it
because it's already wearing a bathing
suit
how's the water nice man finalized best
head covered in beats and more
adjustments a little bit of card
underneath to keep it more solid so it
won't move as much in theory and then
strings underneath to hold it more in
place as he's popping up so it won't
come up so much going through to keep
this ground stable a little bit you know
that Evo Glee returns I'm not going back
here would imagine you hitting the
attack button looking upset yes back up
yeah yeah like 2 or 3 inches okay put
your head back up in place
I put your hands in the front a little
bit guard your eyes yeah there we go
still in there ready and action
[Laughter]
solid